Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update on the latest call of duty game
Call of Duty fans are in luck as
Activision today started rolling out the
first details on this year's installment
the game is in development at
sledgehammer games who you probably know
best as the co-developer of 2011's call
of duty modern warfare 3 a new teaser
website for the game went live today
with a flickering image and a line of
text telling gamers to quote get ready
for a new era of Call of Duty this new
era probably has something to do with
private military corporations better
known as pmcs how do we know well
Activision teamed up with news
organization vice for a new video series
that says in the next Call of Duty the
world's most powerful military is not a
country it's a cooperation you won't
have to wait much longer for more
details on the game as Activision is
promising a quote world reveal on Sunday
May fourth around one p.m. eastern time
there's little in the way of concrete
specifics for the game so far but a
teaser image shows the Golden Gate
Bridge suggesting San Francisco may be
one of the game's locations separately
game informer has obtained the game's
first screenshot which shows off a
soldier who bears an uncanny resemblance
to Idris Elba in some kind of mech suit
didn't some other first-person shooter
recently feature mechs some giant attack
robots something I don't know for more
on this year's call of duty game be sure
to stay tuned to gamespot com this
weekend as the news breaks